تعالج ابني بالتركيه
ورجعت اجازه لهون صار الزلزال وبعدها لما
طلعنا قالوا انه خلص الحدود سكرت والصغير
يعني تعب عليها يعني كتير وضعه تازم اكثر
من اول
[موسيقى]
الزل الاخير اللي ضرب المنطقه في عنا الاف
مرضى السرطان هذا المرضى وضعه عن الماده
كثير سيء كانوا سابقا يروحوا على تركيا
ولكن في هاي الفتره تم تسكير الحدود
التركيه ما في اي مريض حاليا بيحسن يتدوى
في الارض التركيه علما انه العلاج المتوفر
هو فقط موجود في تركيا اما حاليا في شمال
غرب سوريا ضمن المنطقه
الادويه اللي متوفره هي ادويه جزئيه فقط
ما بتكفي كل مرضى السرطان
[موسيقى]
نحتاج احيانا صور لتقييم المرحله اللي
وصلنا لها في العلاج وهل في استجابه ولا
لا في عنا اجهزه غير متوفره لدينا وحصل
لازم ينزل على تركيا المريض كرمال بس ياخذ
يسوي صوره ويرجع لعنا فبكون العلاج ناقص
غير مثالي بالنسبه لهذول المرضى
[موسيقى]
في البيت عم بيعانوا من الالم ما في اي
شيء تقدم لهم علاج تلطيف عباره عن مسكن
الم والواقع صعب جدا والنهايه سيئه جدا
للاسف يعني بس عم نعد ايام والنهايه وفاه
يعني اذا ما تقدم له للعلاج
[موسيقى]